customers are waiting and Casimir
haven't served a single dish we've said
eight minutes we're now in 12 minutes
how long for the first risotto you have
two minutes two minutes
thank you let's go so he's another
servant while you get the next one ready
come on bye Pete look at me please can
you look at me I got no come here poke
you minute look so can he not serve that
while you get the next one ready only
guys please
finally the risotto leads the kitchen
system now yes yes sorry I know it's
hard getting out the traps I appreciate
that I need a [ __ ] system working
otherwise we're going to sink yes yes
sink sink sink
although the boys are sending out food
slowly their parents are doing their
best to be charming so this is a new
potato risotto with wild mushrooms and
rosemary oil just playing with mines
with different textures but first
restaurant Casimir defeated on the
weight of the final was the fantastic
Italian minuta from London
what will head chef Santino think of
their starter they're pushing the
boundaries further they're taking what
results always and saying they say the
right side replace with potato I mean
who the hell would do that I mean but it
really did work very clever
kazimierz food is going down well but
the boys are warring he disorganized
that was [ __ ] let me tell you why
you can't stand there were your head in
a pan and then run up the hot plate and
start serving food and you can't stand
there my man and look around him you've
got to work together yes pop-up tandem
was amazing yes roll off the road
amazing but there seems to be no system
here today got to get a system come on
made time to find out what my experts
made of Casimir starter a result of
how's it delicious slightly salty for me
but very overall flavor I thought was
delicious would that taste better than a
normal rock toad done with a boar oh
right what we said what is the point is
a point in how they're always trying to
do something different they're always
pushing it you're inventing things
that's quite fun that's it work yes or
no I love it did it work yes or no yeah
yes it worked